[Hank] Do you know how the videos start?
[Wheezy] Uhhh, How your videos start?
-Yah.
-Yes.
Good morning John.
-Good Job!
*breathy voice* Vlogbrothers!
What do-How do you wanna start?
-Wheezy Waiter!
*beat boxing*
-Why don't I have theme music?
-How bout I- I'll make one for you.
*breathy voice* Vlogbrothers!
-The great thing is that i'm gonna put that in as the intro
and *then* we're gonna have that conversation.
- *chuckle* That's good; I love it!
-So, people have suggested things that we should do together
and questions that we should ask each other.
-Ok.
-Let's start with this question:
-Wait, so if I have a face for a butt, does that mean I have a butt for--
-No-no
-I just would have Tw-Two faces
-Just two faces.
-Two faces?
-Butt face and Face face.
-Well, obviously I would--
-Yeah, two faces!
-Two Faces, because I need to eat!
[laughter]
-If you had a butt-face you would eat through the butt
and poop through your other butt.
Not that I'm saying that you would poop out your face
-But the butt wouldn't have any teeth, would it? Would that butt have any teeth?
-I think it would just be smoothies.
No, I mean like the thing is that no one ever sees your butt so no one has to know!
-But you would have to sit on it.
-Let's do a suggestion for an activity.
-k.
It's really easy to hide in front of a camera.
[screams]
-Jessica wants us to play "one-word story". Do you know what that is?
-Yes, we just-we just make a story with one word at a time?
-Yeah.
[alternating words] The big giant had money,
so, he decided to make more dogs lackadaisically
put monkeys in other cupboards.
[H] Ante says:
I think he probably means "eagle".
-D'you have an eagle in here?
-Oh, they're all over the place.
-Oh there's one!
-They're comin' at us now!
-Who's the competition?
-Gotta get lots!
I don't know who won, but I'll find out when I'm editing.
-Ok, alright.
[indistinct]
-Wow, that last one was satisfying.
-Aaah, we''re 36-year-old men, aren't we?
-I've always wanted to get punched by a Wheezy clone.
-I'll go get a Wheezy clone.
-Ok.
-Ok, hello I'm a clone
of Wheezy Waiter.
-Wow! You've [indistinct] this
really easy for me.
-[laughs] I don't know what you mean.
You ready to be punched?
-I think I'm ready. Finally my dreams are coming true.
-Ngh!
-It was good.
--which is a thing that I feel like doing anyway after this week.
-Ok.
-Alright.
Three, Two, One...
[screams]
[both] We did it. We did it.
[H] I think that this is the man old man noise:
[strained grunt]
[laughter]
[W] I do that.
[strained grunts]
[grunts] Well, it's time to go.
I don't know why I feel the need to tighten up when you're standing
'cause I can talk normal while standing up
or sitting down, but sometimes I will actually go like this [grunts].
didn't come here about pooping right now
at SUNY says pillow fight
well why Michael Aranda suggest a day in
the life of orange green starring Hank
green his dad and craig benzine as baby
boy okay great thanks for joining me on
this exceptionally weird episode of a
logarithm which i distract myself from
the current state of the world you're
welcome i'm here for you Hank thanks for
letting me be here instead of you know
probably NN a gutter somewhere or maybe
you might be in a hotel room changing
pants using my pants are dirty
thanks for joining us why don't we save
the end of the videos John be on Tuesday
doing
I did yeah thanks Greg you can click
over here maybe to go to his YouTube
channel it's good stuff and he's going
to be a nerd counterfeit area in Boston
february2014 26 that was fun
there's a longer version this video also
on Hanks channel